let me continue michael brewery from the
movie big short
uh he predicted the 2008 market uh
housing crash
uh he recently compared a market slump
to plane crash and said the tumbling
stocks and home sales remind him of the
housing bubble bursting as i said about
2008 it's like watching a plane crash he
said it hurts it's not fun and i'm not
smiling he said on twitter recently
burry shot to fame after he made a
fortune betting on the housing market
crash in 2007 and 8 and made a fortune
betting on it bury also predicted the
next market crash will dwarf to 2008 bus
would spark the global financial crisis
now here you may say he has some
motive here because he's involved in the
next one you may be right but he was
able to predict the last one and people
thought he was crazy he was able to say
some of these big companies are going to
go out of business they thought he was
crazy he ended up being a right they
made a movie about him and many of us
watched it the other day on
my instagram account for pbd podcast i
said there's two movies everybody's
gotta watch in america today uh margin
call and big short
the the video on instagram got 500 000
likes 11 million views why do you think
everyone's trying to find out what the
hell is going on with the economy this
is on an instagram account with only 45
000 followers i got 40 some thousand
followers not even my main account it's
just our podcast account
everybody is curious to find out what's
going on today so now let me keep going
i'm still going to explain to you the
quantitative typing and easing but
here's mark's up zuckerberg love them or
hate them if i had to bet
i'd say that this might be one of the
worst downturns that we've seen in
recent history zuckerberg said in a
weekly employee q a session audio of
which was heard by reuters fyi
why would an employer tell their
employees this is the worst we're going
to see ever why would you say that
isn't the ceo and the founder supposed
to uplift everybody
aren't they everything's going to be
okay
good for him to just being straight up
with their employees now again tell me
what's the benefit of him saying that
motive
what's the benefit of him saying that as
a result of the expected downturn meta
has reduced his hiring goal for 2022
from 10 000 engineers to 6 000 to 7 000.
zuckerberg also indicated his hope that
individuals who weren't making the cut
will end up leaving the company remember
that whole cycle less disposable income
less spending
lower profits layoffs unemployment this
is do you see what's going on with that
cycle this is kind of what the
explanation of that cycle is so now
google
the uncertain global economic outlook
has been top of our mind
on top of mind like all companies we're
not immune to economic headwinds we'll
be slowing the pace of hiring for the
rest of the year while still supporting
our most important opportunities google
needs to be more entrepreneurial working
with greater urgency sharper focus and
more hunger than we've shown on sunnier
days
and then we have our friend here dave
ramsey inflation is not going to kill
you he's right that's not going to kill
you physically it's not going to happen
so that's a factual statement
fear porn comments talking about
everybody is trying to it's going to be
all right folks it's going to be all
right it's not always as simple as
supply and demand but it almost always
is that's why this situation is not the
same as 2008 facts and evidence support
why today's real estate market is not
going to crash
he may be right
but someone's going to be right and
someone's going to be wrong in the next
6 12 18 months he just may be right but
to listen to what our friend here dave
has to say that means you have to say
jamie diamond is wrong michael berry is
wrong and a lot of these other guys that
this is their business what they do for
a living that they have access to more
data points
a chase has access to the kind of data
very maybe a handful of companies have
access to google
facebook chase these may be top three
out of five companies in the world that
have access to more data than any other
company maybe amazon has to go in there
and apple's got to go in there
they kind of can see some of
these things taking place so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]